[Música]
eu sou professora e pelas minhas
andanças pelo brasil e já se passaram 30
anos
eu praticamente moro dentro de um avião
a gente escuta é a nossa área muitos
clichês um deles você já deve ter ouvido
é aquele que diz que a escola do século
o professor é do século 21 o aluno do
século 21
portanto uma equação impossível de ser
resolvido
outra máxima que a gente escuta é que a
educação no brasil vai mal porque a
formação de professores é ruim o que não
é dito em momento nenhum é que a
situação da educação no brasil que têm
índices tão alarmantes
ela só existe porque vivemos numa
sociedade que se diz responsabiliza do
seu papel educativo cobrando da escola o
que ela não faz
então meu compromisso com os professores
é sair por aí pelo brasil pra dizer para
eles que ele sim é de fato a força que
pode mudar a educação porque não existe
solução que venha de cima para baixo
existe falsas soluções
quem muda de verdade é quem está todo
dia lá e ser professor não é por missão
e nem por falta de opção ser professor é
um trabalho intelectual da maior
importância todos vocês são capazes de
se lembrar de um ou mais de um professor
que fez a total mudança na vida de vocês
só o professor é capaz de olhar para
cada um dos seus alunos
e é a sua platéia cativa e dizer 'você
vai ser grande
você é capaz de aprender tudo o que você
quiser você de fato tem a força da
mudança mas para ele fazer isso ele tem
que acima de tudo parar de fazer o que
não é de sua responsabilidade para de
ser policial pára de ser babá para
descer porteiro parar de ser psicólogo
para descer todas as coisas que jogam
nas costas da gente
esse é simplesmente professor que já é
muita coisa porque tem gente que faz
chocolate tem gente que constrói imóveis
mas quem faz gente de verdade somos nós
o professor e eu luto pra que a gente
olhe o maior orgulho e diga para as
pessoas muito prazer eu sou professora e
isso é que faz toda a diferença quando
eu converso com os professores
ele sempre começam quando me perguntam
começam com como me pedindo respostas e
eu sempre respondo que toda vez que a
gente procura a resposta fora da gente
será uma falsa resposta ele que tem que
buscar essa solução em colaboração com
outros professores com aqueles que estão
no chão da escola e nem não com aqueles
que acham que sabe o que não sabem
daqueles que estão ali todo dia
enfrentando todos os problemas da escola
então é eu sempre quanto em minhas
palestras algumas pessoas chegavam para
mim assim professora muito obrigada pela
sua palestra motivacional
no começo eu ficava muito frustrada
porque eu me sentia meio guru de
autoajuda e até que um dia uma
professora explicou
ela falou pra mim
a professora eu tudo o que a senhora
falou entende só não sabia que eu sabia
a senhora ligou os pontinhos e eu achei
o máximo essa definição porque o que é
motivacional não é autoajuda é porque
ela ajuda faz muito mal na educação o
que faz a diferença é a gente tem a
capacidade de ligar os pontinhos e essa
ligar os pontinhos ela vem pela
experiência vem pela aquilo que eu vivo
portanto o professor tem que parar um
automatismo da ação tem que entrar em
contato
tem que parar para olhar para para ouvir
para refletir parar de ser um aplicador
de exames para apenas vão que a escola
parar de reproduzir aquilo que dizem que
a gente deve ensinar a gente tem que
chorar tem que ter coragem de jogar fora
aqueles conteúdos que dizem que é pra
gente ensinar que ligo nada a coisa
nenhuma
a gente precisa desacelerar a gente
precisa parar de fazer o que não presta
pra nada a gente tem que dizer eu sei o
que eu estou fazendo porque eu sou um
intelectual e o trabalho é muito muito
difícil por isso eu quero dizer para
vocês que eu odeio dia do professor o
dia do professor para mim devia se
chamar o dia da revolta porque a gente
não deveria aceitar sob nenhuma hipótese
um dia de homenagem a gente deveria
exigir o ano inteiro de respeito à vida
inteira de respeito do que é o nosso
papel
é muito maior do que a sociedade diz que
é está na hora da sociedade que diz o
tempo inteiro que a educação é
importante parar de cobrar da escola e
do professor aquilo que ela não é capaz
de fazer
portanto ando por aí pelo brasil ano
passado falei com quase 13 mil
professores fazendo com que o olho deles
pudessem brilhar para sair dali com a
certeza absoluta que eu não estou
fazendo auto ajuda
eu tô simplesmente dizendo que ele tem o
poder e que ele precisa assumir esse
poder ele precisa ter orgulho daquilo
que ele está fazendo porque ele é sem
dúvida o profissional mais importante
que existe porque ele faz gente e isso a
gente tem que se orgulhar de fazer é
esse legado
[Aplausos]